[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i am dave ramsey your host we
invite your calls nationwide toll free
the number is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it the phone number triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so i have had the pleasure of spending
the morning with a ramsey
uh foundations in personal fire ramsay
um i'm sorry certified financial coaches
and uh they have done all kinds of
things so been in here learning all week
i'll be here most of the week learning
we've got an enrichment series going uh
we've got about we have several thousand
coaches across america
and people with big old hearts and big
old brains both to help you
with your finances and i'm coaching them
through
and giving them some ideas of stuff i
used to do back in the day and lots of
things ramsay is doing today to do
one-on-one coaching and to help someone
change their lives
and it occurred to me that some of those
lessons that we're talking to those guys
about are probably good for some of uh
some of our audience from our listening
audience as well
here's the thing that we discovered
that is a huge difference maker for you
now i get tons of people that don't like
dave ramsey because there is a segment
of people in our
culture that
don't like to be told
that they can win
if i tell someone that is hell-bent on
being a victim
that they can win
they don't like it
it makes them mad
don't tell me i can win because then i
that takes away all my excuses
it takes away the fact that i might have
to deal with the person in my mirror
and i if i convince you that your
category whatever category you have
stuck yourself in
i'm skinny i'm fat i'm man i'm woman i'm
black i'm white i'm purple i'm pink i'm
latino
i don't know what i am
i'm from the north i'm from the south
i have this or that
i don't know what your thing is but i
can tell you after 30 years of doing
this i've met one just like you who made
it
and if you want to live in the soup of
your self-pity and in the soup of your
victimhood uh you're going to not like
dave ramsey
so personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
and once you get that dialed in
then you're in a place to go okay yes
there's outside variables
yes sometimes there's mean people in the
world yes sometimes there's racists
sometimes they're sexists sometimes
there's a whatever ist that's there's
jerks and foolish and ignorant people
everywhere
they're all around us
and yet it's still your job to control
what you can control and they're not one
of the things you can control
you can control the person in your
mirror
and then you
become successful
tada
is it easy well crap no if it was easy
we would not recommend successful people
so
last summer uh i guess it was last
summer we had at our entre leadership
event uh
one of the sharks from the shark tank
and uh he and some of his folks and some
other friends of mine all got together
at my house for a big dinner afterwards
we ended up sitting on my deck and
talking until the wee hours of the
morning and became
that night lifelong friends i'll just
tell you i just love this guy and i
heard he was doing a new project an
audible project and i got him on the
phone because i want you guys to know
about it so
uh america's shark you gotta love him
damon john is with us hey my friend how
are you
what's up brother i uh i love what you
were saying as i just tuned in and um
and yes it was a very it was an amazing
experience being with you and your
family and everybody so really good to
hear from you man well it's good to hear
from you i'm excited about this project
so you're gonna tell people
how you built a six billion dollar brand
called fubu
uh i mean we get to see on the shark but
that's small potatoes compared to fubu
and you did this man started i mean 40
bucks you are a rags to riches story and
you overcame some crap without a doubt
to do that i mean you got misunderstood
abused and betrayed and everything else
and still pulled it off and which
normally happens to all of us but
sometimes people think that line of
success doesn't include that much manure
but it did in your case it did in my
case for sure that's one of the reasons
we became fast friends but talk about
this new audible original uh about
founding fubu what are you talking about
in this
yeah yeah so the waterloo original is so
there's there is no book to this that
has now become an audible this is purely
an audible original greatly produced it
is talking about my my days that i
founded what i went through all the
things and all that all the things that
happened to me good bad or ugly a lot of
behind the scenes stories such as you
know you start having money come around
there's bad people and good people to
come around i didn't think though that
for your lessons that they can learn
from is the the community that was built
you know the same way you know we're
seeing too many communities that are
fighting because they're apart we're not
getting enough of the good stories of
people who listen to your show they
couldn't care less about other people's
color gender and race and all that other
stuff it's about communities you build
and and and really how we ended up
growing and how i made a ton of
financial mistakes a ton meaning
closing fubu three times from 89 to 92
running out of the first hundred
thousand dollars that i had and almost
being homeless and then blowing around
20 million dollars when i first made
money and i think that's important for
people to learn too because you know
fiscal education and responsibility is
something that you learn every day you
keep growing there's no way to just
arrive at it and i think that a lot of
your listeners can absolutely take away
from those big mistakes that i made and
thank god i'm still here
after making those mistakes
what was the best
financial decisions the best three
decisions best three habits or
disciplines
around money that you develop that you
attribute to being able to stay on top
of it
i think uh living within my means
and understanding that i think um
understanding credit
um
and i also think um probably in general
understanding how money works from a
taxes perspective uh
from interest uh and understanding how
to allocate it accordingly and i think
all three of those really uh kind of
kind of stay in tune and align with each
other um but you're gonna say three i
think that it's going to be the fourth
one also the investment you know being
able to not only have to go out and work
for my money but letting my money work
for me and not you know not taking as
many chances as you know i took in the
past because i had money i made my my
most my most ignorant um
or my most uneducated decisions was when
i had the most money that's when i made
the biggest mistakes
well you get you kind of get fat and
sloppy we all do right
yeah it's kind of like yeah that little
bit don't matter that little bit doesn't
matter i got it i got it all of a sudden
you're like holy crap i don't got it
you know how many of the sharks how many
of the shark deals are paying you money
right now are you still making a profit
on
um i would i would think that around
three out of ten i make a profit on um
uh probably two out of you know because
our two out of ten are kind of the
the kind of trying to figure out who
they want to be when they grow up and
then the other five out of 10 they just
didn't work out they uh um you know i
don't want to talk bad about the
entrepreneur maybe in their time but you
know they made bad decisions or
uh you know they didn't educate
themselves enough it's a three-hour
audible project called founding fubu you
can listen to it at daymondjohn.com is
that right damon
absolutely all right be sure and check
it out guys this guy's awesome thank you
damon
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and author of
the new book that's in pre-sale from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love is my co-host he and
i were both speaking this morning at the
enrichment
event for the uh ramsey financial
coaches uh and uh
it was a lot of fun you did a great job
of course thank you sir a lot of fun you
you warmed them up it's always nice to
follow you you you know the crowd's
ready you know they're fired you know
the bar set low
whatever
yeah no not the case it was a great
crowd these are the men and women on the
front lines who have decided because of
the baby steps and the life change and
transformation that they
uh brought into their life as a result
of that clear path now they're out there
coaching other men and women and giving
hope and and you know it's just always a
blessing to be able to to look eyeball
to eyeball with those men and women who
care deeply about coaching others so it
was really really sweet sweet crowd and
fun time well and they know they're why
they're clear
they're very missional and that's your
whole message of the skin coleman show
and is with your career to be missional
find something you love
and pour yourself into it so if you want
to talk careers ken is with us today you
want to talk jobs ken's with us of
course we'll talk about your life and
your money this is the ramsay show so
it's all about you
wiley is with us in reno nevada hi wiley
how are you
doing well dave uh hi ken how are you
guys great having a blast
how can we help hey
so my question um i'm currently debt
free i've been listening to you for the
last uh two years paid off all my debt
um
my mom turned me on to you and i got out
of college debt-free so i'm currently in
baby step four and i'm saving 15
of um
of my retirement uh and i have i have
currently worked for the school district
here so i have a retirement through the
district the pension um i have a 403 b
and a roth ira that i'm all contributing
to look at you well done
thank you um it's all due to you um and
everything that you've got to eat i
didn't give you any money
true
uh so i'm just trying to look forward to
my future i'm looking to buy a house
should i stop investing in these and
just stack money or should i continue to
invest in one or is there a certain one
that's better than the other either one
is fine
people do all three things once you get
to baby step three which means you have
your emergency fund in place and you're
debt-free which you did a while back way
to go
then is when you start saving for a
house sometimes people wait a little bit
particularly if they're young like you
they wait a little bit to start their
investing and use all that margin to
pile up a big old down payment and
there's nothing wrong with doing that i
don't want you to wait more than three
years but if you want to take a couple
years and pile up a down payment and
hold on baby step four we we always call
that baby step 3b around here
other people look at it and go i can
still save pretty aggressively while
doing my investing so i'm going to just
dial some of my investing back but i'm
going to do this other one over here
that's really sweet i don't want to i
don't want to get completely out and uh
can we see people go up and down that
spectrum and they all do well yeah
because what happens is when you get to
that baby step three and you move to
three being you're looking out you have
all this freedom you get to decide what
really really matters you've got the
discipline you've done the hard work so
now it really is i like that either or
what's most important now and begin to
move with the same discipline the same
purpose that you have been no you'll get
there we do not say that about paying
off your house sir no
we say do the 15 that's right and
whatever you can find above that pay
your house off early but for saving for
the down payment on the first house
that's right a lot of people uh you know
in their 20s or 30s will take a
temporary pause
on baby step four a gap year oh i like
that day between three and four and they
all build their down payment right and
that's baby step 3b i've never thought
of it that way i haven't either actually
it's good that's pretty good i like that
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five tyler
is in abilene texas hey tyler how are
you
i'm doing great dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
well uh me and my wife are new to you uh
we got married in june congratulations
from the ground running we
we knew debt was a bad idea
uh she came into the marriage debt free
i did not by a long stretch
um so he as soon as we got married got
back from the honeymoon started
attacking debt
and working together to pay it off um we
really haven't argued about money at all
until last night so i wanted
our tiebreaker so uh-oh oh boy okay
so what what is the argument about this
is great i'll get my whistle out my
little stripe my little striped i need a
flag too i could throw a flag on him
yeah that's it yeah all right go tyler
what's the argument
all right so i'm a youth pastor
and we were talking about
once we get out of baby step two about
investing
and my cpa has talked to me a little bit
about possibly filing an exemption for
social security taxes
uh my wife is concerned uh about doing
that in case you know the what-ifs could
happen if i
injured and couldn't work or or whatever
or disability wouldn't be wouldn't be a
factor
and my mind behind it being a real uh
numbers-minded person
say well we can make a lot more
investing that we're getting out of debt
quicker if we opted out of the social
security
i didn't know what you would
advise in that
either direction or
neither at all
darn darn darn
i don't get to blow my whistle
you're both right yeah
so let me walk you through what how we
handle this okay
um yes i believe pastors
should opt out of social security
uh in order to do that you have to sign
a document that it says you're a
conscientious objector that only has a
religious basis
you do not believe
in the social security
system and it's only for your pastoral
income by the way if you have another
income that income subject social
security it's only for your pastoral
income now i could sign that with good
conscience because i believe the bible
teaches us to be good managers good
stewards of money and giving money to
the social security system is by
definition not being a good steward
and so that's not a joke that's just a
math i mean that's a morality fact as
far as i'm concerned and so you're not
being a good manager if you give the
government money and you didn't have to
so i can i could in good conscience be a
conscientious objector i don't have that
option because i'm not a pastor so
yes i would opt out and yes you're right
you would make more money by investing
that money putting it in a fruit jar you
would end up with more
than giving it to them it has a negative
rate of return the social security
system does on average plus when you die
they keep the money you put in and use
it for the other people okay versus if
you put it in a fruit jar when you die
if your relatives can find it you'd be
okay they would have it get the metal
detector out in the backyard like
they'll be at my place right because i
bury coffee cans everybody knows that
not but anyway so um
now your wife is also correct the social
security system does three things that
you would be unwise
to
step away from the social security
system without covering for those three
things
one
is disability
uh and you would not be getting ssi or
social security disability if you became
disabled so you need to buy long-term
disability insurance before you opt out
oh you need to do that whether you opt
out or not because the social security
disability is not enough to live on
so everyone needs long-term disability
insurance anyway okay
the second thing is you will not be
receiving disability at our social
security at retirement
so uh you will need to save for
retirement oh wait a minute you need to
do that anyway because we've already
covered they suck the rate of return the
money you're going to get at retirement
is awful you'll be eating alpo so you
need to have a retirement account but
not doing a retirement account not doing
this social security and not having a
disability account and then you retire
broke or you get disabled and no policy
your wife is right that would be really
dumb okay and the third one is and it's
not applicable yet but if you have
children
and you die your children get paid
social security until they reach 18
on your behalf and you would need to buy
life insurance to make sure your family
is taken care of in the event of you
dying before you're rich oh wait you
need to do that anyway
because the social security coming to
your kids is not going to be enough and
so i could consciously conscientiously
object and step out but you've got to
cover disability death and retirement
but you got to do that
anyway
i'm thinking about being a pastor dave
all of a sudden so i can opt out part
time of course dave i'm not leaving
oh
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just thirty dollars a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is our
co-host today here on the ramsey show
i'm your host dave ramsey the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you feel like
you're constantly running but nothing
you do ever moves the needle you can't
get off the wheel your money your life
you know that's normal most people feel
that way
but right now in our world normal it's
frustrating it's all exhausting
all the time
but you can live the life you want where
you're dead free where you actually have
breathing room in your time and your
money but it takes having a game plan
and that's why we want you to join us
for our game plan live
we're doing a free
live stream on september 28th me dave
ramsey christy wright and george
campbell and we're going to help you set
a foundation for your goals and your
money we're going to give you a game
plan
now i don't know what normal is anymore
who knows what normal is i want to go
back to normal i'm not sure i want to
get back to normal i want things like
the old days i don't want things like
the old days
the old days had outhouses and cars that
didn't have disc brakes and didn't have
penicillin i i don't want the old days
um
you know i i i like it the way it is and
so life life is pretty good but normal
as of two years ago i'd settle for that
but i don't think you're gonna see that
again i think we have a different world
now so let's learn to live
let's learn to live and not sit on the
sidelines and throw grenades so we're
going to give you a
game plan september 28th to register for
the game plan live
stream text game plan to 33 789 text
game plan all one word two three three
seven
eight
nine open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five marissa is in
bend oregon hi marissa how can ken and i
help
hi thank you for taking my call
my husband and i we are
really frustrated living in oregon right
now and so
we are wanting to move somewhere that um
to a state that is more in line with our
values and what we want for the future
for our children
and we are in the middle of baby steps
three and four
so just trying to you know your
advertisement about a game plan so just
trying to figure out what would be the
best game plan to
plan a move like this something we had
not planned on doing
um at all we both were born and raised
in oregon but it's just it's just too
much we just
it's so heartbreaking the place you were
born the place you love the place you
were raised doesn't feel like home
anymore no not at all yeah so what is
that what are the key things that are
driving you out of there
um so a lot of it is just you know the
unrelenting mandates
um i work for state government my
husband works for a
indian tribe here
so it just is you know one thing after
another our kids are just being
bombarded by
you know liberal anti-christian
views um when they're in school we
actually live in more of a rural area so
we don't have any other schooling
options for them
um
so those are just the two big things a
lot of the politics just you know the
constant um
socialist ideas that are being passed
down in oregon
so i mean all of it
well the reason i ask is not to stir up
trouble but i think it is good for
elected officials to hear
why their citizens are leaving
right
um and it's happening in california new
york and mass
it's happening in oregon and washington
state
um it's happening around some of the
major cities where the city has lost
control
they lost control of their cities
and um and
people are they are not you know people
who are the producers in our culture who
are the peop the artists who make the
art the business people who run the
businesses the administrators who
administrate the good moms and dads who
do show up at the pta meetings uh
they've lost their tolerance for this
stuff and um we're seeing one of the
biggest migrations in the history of the
united states right now is since the
time that this country was actually
settled
it's it's pretty bizarre so that's why i
bring it up it's kind of a philosophical
thing but worth talking about yeah
marissa i'm curious if you could tell
dave and i uh what's driving the
destination the most is it the where or
is it the what what you guys will need
to do uh from a professional standpoint
just curious
well i i actually work in a prison here
in oregon so you know my career field
i'm not necessarily anticipating being
able to stay in um
but my husband is a farmer uh he
actually farms for
like i said a native american tribe for
their tribal government so he's very
much i mean he has an ag degree from
texas so that's kind of why we're
looking at texas he's
you know familiar with texas really
liked going to school there
so his degree is in ag economics so he
can run
any part of a farm from the business end
to the manual end so
we're just right now we're focusing on
getting him a job and where where would
that be what would that look like
especially in the midwest i mean even
just uh job opportunities for him in
oregon the farming community were
they're out of water like
you know so
his his opportunities regardless of the
politics are becoming few and far
between so
um so that's another another thing
that's driving our desire to move is
career opportunities as well what do you
what do you do tactically just the
function in the prison system what kind
of a job is it administrative in nature
what do you do right now i run a life
skills program so transitioning work so
i can do that kind of stuff in a variety
of settings
and i also have uh experience in
administration so okay great so
i'm a little bit more marketable yes you
are
you know working for a different type of
environment
your career field might be can correct
me if i'm wrong more defined by what you
do rather than where i think that's been
doing it so i really wouldn't i mean i
think it's i've been running a life
skills program i've been in
administration oh by the way happened to
be yes in a prison system yeah i agree
so once you guys get where the the right
gig is for the hubs
this is a wonderful wonderful job market
right now and you're going to be very
very attractive to a lot of different
people so i just wanted to ask about
that so i think dave at this point it's
you know okay we got to figure out the
place we've got a wonderful relocation
guide that i do want to make sure kelly
gives them uh at the end of this call we
had a ramsey relocation guide it's freed
it really helps you walk through a
checklist of everything from real estate
professional uh schools packing
everything you can imagine it's part of
the thing that freaks people out about a
move is not having a plan you know it's
just like what do i think of there's a
million things and certainly when you're
uprooting from one state and moving
cross-country that's terrifying but we
do have a great tool we want to give her
that'll help i don't even know that you
didn't know that yeah i talk about on
the ken coleman shows we have a lot of
people changing jobs
and so yeah
i guess i ought to know these things i'd
give them away yeah it's a checklist so
it helps you come up with a plan marissa
we have this great relation no okay
anyway the um
the thing that comes to mind for me is i
i always have to put stuff like this how
do you eat an elephant a bite at a time
you said how do you lay out a game plan
i always have to put stuff that's this
big a task in
order
uh almost like a flow chart until this
happens i can't go to the next thing
and the first thing for you guys is to
land careers right
you can't go on a wing and a prayer and
hope somebody hires you
so when you if you both had jobs making
more or equal to what you're making now
in a new market now moving starts to be
mathematically fairly easy
and that's another thing that's been
overwhelming is um you know
just the cost of living and our salaries
here are
quite a bit more than when i look at
like texas oklahoma kind of midwest
um but i also know that we're going to
be able to buy a house that's probably
half the price of our house here you
know so just trying to keep things those
things in perspective too but when you
look at it
you can make you can land
you can land the career
with a track uh uh you know land the
position both of you
then in whatever city and you say okay
that's where we're going then you can
start unraveling the stuff on your end
and making the leap but making the leap
until you have the income waiting on you
at the new place
is um that's really dangerous and so
that would be my biggest and first thing
i would do if i were in your shoes is to
you know jump on king coleman's site use
all of his tools to land that job you
love and this may be a time to
transition into a different segment of
your career field that gives you more
meaning yeah as well but landon land
that first and then you can talk about
selling your house buying a house you
can talk about moving you can talk about
uh actually loading up the truck and
heading to beverly hills it is swimming
pools and movie stars texas tea
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today his new book is called from
paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
you can get it at
ramseysolutions.com and if you pre-order
it because it will come out in early
november and you should pre-order it you
will get over a hundred dollars worth of
items with it including the e-book
including the
uh the audio book inc including what's
other stuff in there well you're going
to get the the get hired course which is
our digital course it really gives you
the edge to beat the competition it's a
wonderful little course we've got the
live stream event coming up november uh
we've got so many more goodies that are
practical tools that are kind of in a
suite there so that's where it gets you
that incredible value so that is a
fantastic it's kind of like you get all
the tools that allow you to beat the
competition that's what we're trying to
put together here to give people the
edge it's competitive right now that's
the way it happens yeah this is the
ramsey show triple eight eight two five
five two two five jim's in sacramento hi
jim how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up good i've got a little bit of
a pickle here we uh we sold one of our
rental properties out here in california
and we have approximately 310 000 in a
1031 exchange
by the time we were able to evict our
tenants and get out the market has kind
of climbed a little bit higher
we have uh we have emergency fund we're
on baby step seven no bills
and uh but the problem is we're kind of
just short on cash
without liquidating our emergency fund
out to buy another rental property
um
obviously don't want to take a loan but
i also don't want to pay
60 plus thousand in taxes what would you
do
you have 310 000
yes sir i buy 310 000 rental property
you can't you can't find them out here
that's that's not true
you can't find one you like
correct
but they're there i have i have my
emergency fund as well as some
additional cash but it would
take my emergency debt fund down to just
a low amount
explain to me what that means how much
money are you talking about
uh we typically keep about 30 000 in our
emergency fund so you're telling me you
cannot find a property for 310 but you
can for 340.
uh they're running well i have
additional money as well i have
additional 50 or so 40 50 000 in cash
but i don't want to want to liquidate
every dime i have down you know i would
have to go down but i mean you're
telling me you can find a house for 360
but not 310.
yeah it's pretty close yeah
yeah and the market is crazy hot
well i know that
but
um
well
you can do what you want to do i'm i
think you uh
i it's just illogical that you can find
360 but can't fight 310.
i mean if you told me you can't find
anything for under 600
uh
but so my 310 won't work
you know i
will argue about that that's that's at
least a logic argument logical argument
but three 360 versus 310 that could be a
matter of negotiation that could be a
matter of finding one that needs the
gutters replaced
correct yeah now i understand we're
looking at right about 380 390 and i
have the cash for that you have a
particular property you've fallen in
love with
no absolutely i don't fall in love with
real estate
you have a particular property you have
your eye on
we do we just we're down to about 14
days to identify a property in that 1031
so we want to you know we've had we've
got two two or three we're looking at
right now and they're right about 380
390. um it just puts my emergency fund
you know down to about 1000 bucks
we make about 220 230 depending on
bonuses so your emergency fund's down
for one month or two months yeah yeah
that's kind of my thought yeah yeah yeah
i think you rebuild the emergency fund
like it's an emergency and you close on
something if you've got 13 days
but moral of the story is don't wait
until you paint yourself into a 13-day
corner so you get desperate and have to
make a move that's pinchy because this
is pinchy it feels pinchy but this is
all because not wanting to pay capital
gains yeah you could buy less that's
yeah
um and you could buy uh you know
hypothetically
you know go to another market even go
100 miles away that's what i'm wondering
if you can buy and buy 200 000 property
you're going to pick apple games on 110
not on 310 then so you only pay on what
you don't use up out of this i despise
taxes you know this i hate them but but
but i mean it doesn't need to be the top
the tail that wakes it up that's what
i'm wondering if it's true it's putting
some false pressure here i don't it's
not false pressure well it's making you
prioritize the wrong thing thank you for
saying that better yes but it's like
make good business decisions first great
tax decisions second yes
not great tax decisions and bad business
decisions that's exactly that's what's
bothering you yeah yeah
i feel like it's just the wrong thing is
is driving the trailer right so i think
you're going to close on a 380 000
property because i think you can't get
your head off of it
uh that's what i think you nailed that i
mean he's got something he goes this is
a good deal if i can get it you know and
he's gonna get it so you make two and a
quarter no don't borrow money um you're
gonna do it and you're gonna take a you
know you're gonna run three months or
four months without a properly funded
emergency fund while you rebuild it with
a 200 000 income and no payments in the
world
so um but
god help you if something breaks in that
new rental the first month
you got no money that never happens
though dave
wow you're the real estate guy
i think it's worth talking about i hate
taxes i do too well i will do
almost anything except a bad deal and
that's what i'm getting now to avoid bad
to avoid paying taxes here's the guys at
baby step seven he's crushed it he's
done a phenomenal job with his money and
to try to avoid capital gains tax when
your capital gains on three hundred
thousand dollars is sixty yeah okay but
capital gains on a hundred thousand is
is you know right fifteen so
um you know you buy something cheaper
too as a possibility but here
guys you you um
the the pro
in the decision making frameworks that
we use all of us use
when you paint yourself into a corner
and you start making statements like
they don't have any of those
that's when i start challenging you
because they always have one of those i
don't even know what those is yet
but there's always another option
when you start telling me there's you
know it's like bless your heart when
you're doing youth ministry and they go
oh
she broke up with me and she's the only
woman on the planet yeah no she's not
yeah but by tuesday you'll see another
one
[Laughter]
that's the truth that's the truth it's
fatalism thing you know god only that's
the one that god picked out for me
there's only one no no there's another
one had a guy say that to me once he
said well what i really mean is she's
the only one that would love mango now
that is possible
you're a real minister aren't you yeah i
really have a heart for people you're
you're a real pastor's heart it was a
buddy chris is in new york hey chris
what's up
hey what's going on fellas
i'm
i'm in a really tough situation right
now
um
i just literally found out probably
about a year ago
i had
a judgment against me since
2012.
i i never knew about it i was never
detected to check my credit or anything
like that
um recently i've been trying to uh build
build my credit
and when i got the letter in the mail i
said wait a minute hold on wait dude
taking me to corporate garnishment so i
did not understand at all why they would
take me to court
come to find out they sent papers that i
was never served in 2012
and they got the judgment against me
because i never appeared to court but i
never before i run out of time chris
what's your question
oh well i'm sorry my question is
is
they my original debt was four thousand
dollars they want
right now twenty thousand dollars i call
and i try to settle with them
basically they said no we want the full
twenty one thousand
what was this debt resulting from
uh this was a credit card debt
okay absolute horse crap they will
settle for 1500 bucks
and if you can't beat them down to that
i know if you can't beat them down to
that on the phone you need to hire an
attorney don't pay them 20 000
it's probably not even collectible in
your state so if it's eight years nine
years ten years old
yeah that's why i'm so confused by it
i'm like
why
like i just didn't understand it well
basically
here's what you've not done here's what
you've not done you've not been
proactive
to start with you knew you had credit
card debt did nothing about it since
2012. and then a year ago you got a
judgment notice and now you're calling
me a year later still working on it
so you need to get on this man and get
this solved
time to put both feet on it
now
if you can't fix it you need to spend
the spend two thousand bucks on an
attorney to fix it and get it solved but
i don't think they can even collect it
but i think you probably settle it for a
thousand couple thousand bucks probably
gonna cost you a thousand attorneys fees
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
ken coleman ramsey personality
and career coach extraordinaire is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
your money your career
and how it all works together we're
answering your questions at triple eight
eight two five
five
two two five
so ken
this is an interesting and distressing
part of our world today
we did at ramsey a couple of years ago
the largest
by far
airtight
research
the largest study
of millionaires in north america in the
united states of america ever done
all the details
where they come from what do they think
about did they inherit their money what
are their careers what's their marital
status what's their race creed color
whatever everything we could figure out
and trying to find a and trying to
figure out okay what does it take
to become a millionaire
in america today a millionaire is a
million dollar net worth for those of
you don't know it's not a billionaire
a billion is a thousand million
it's a lot more
if you have
three thousand dollars you're closer to
being a millionaire than a millionaire
is to being a billionaire
as an example so it's not it's not
private jets and seven cars
okay that's not a millionaire a million
dollar net worth is not that much
it but it is more than most people have
there's about uh 17 million millionaires
in america and that's what you own minus
what you owe
equals your net worth your assets minus
your liabilities is your net worth
so if you have no debt and you have a
million dollars in your 401k you're a
millionaire okay that's simple that kind
of a thing all right so we post on
instagram
yesterday
and this is what is societally
distressing
that from this study
not a feeling that we have
we didn't ask your broke brother-in-law
his opinion
we ask real millionaires 10 freaking
thousand of them
who they are where they come from
and one of the many
conclusions we drew from this was the
top 10
career fields that we found
according to frequency within the study
so who what career field did we find
most often
second most often and so on the most
often we found was engineer
the second was an accountant or cpa the
third was teacher
the fourth was management
the fifth was attorney
so not even making the top five is
medical doctor
by the way there were six
number six
but they were not even in the top five
and we post that on there and instagram
and facebook
proves once again
that humanity is full of morons
i mean if you read comments after
articles or comments after posts like
this you understand why some species eat
they're young
people are dumber than a rock out there
oh yeah a lot of mouthpieces some of you
listening are dumber than a rock i mean
i never heard this is ridiculous so
here's the thing okay we've done
detailed scientific research that proves
that the sun is hot
and we post it yeah on instagram the sun
is hot some of you morons will disagree
with that yeah
just because you think you have a right
to
and you should really stop before you
post something because it makes you look
stupid
okay was that unclear well i thought
probably i i felt like you could have
had a little bit more enthusiasm for
what you were saying i felt like it felt
like it lost a little fervor no i think
you're absolutely right this is data and
you know what's funny is like people
they want to argue like we're duping
people yeah like what we're just saying
yeah right dave ramsey teachers aren't
really making that kind of money not
where i live i'm a teacher teachers
can't be millionaires no way teachers
can be millionaires no teachers should
be on there where are the nurses where
are the nurses well you nurses get your
butt in gear and i guess you'll make the
dead gum list oh my gosh well what
they're missing what these brilliant
mouth breathers have forgotten in this
post is that it has nothing to do with
the salary has everything to do with the
way they live
now engineers certainly can make way
more money than a teacher but it is they
have lived on less than they make they
have saved they have invested they've
walked the clear path the baby steps
their baby steps millionaires and that's
what they're missing here they think oh
i know what a teacher salary is you guys
are just making this stuff up
as if you're into cleveland i'll tell
you what all five share in common all
five professions are systems people
that's right they all work systems yeah
teachers work a a teaching plan they
have a lesson plan they work a system
and they they they if they somebody
gives them a lesson plan they don't go
make up their own yep they they follow
the lesson plan and engineers they don't
make up their own thing the bridge would
fall that's correct they have to follow
the system they have to follow the
processes attorneys have to follow a
process called the law you know you
don't get to make it up you have to
actually adhere to a process all of
these people adhere to processes for a
living and they take that same part of
their personality and they apply it to
their money and voila they become a
millionaire so what is the data on
teacher income well right now the median
income in the united states is 60 000 so
now before some of you folks start
firing shots at me on that i said median
you know what a medium does anybody know
if you've been in a good teacher's class
you would have known it's your law of
averages you just run your averages so
there's no average is different than
median yeah i know but i'm just saying
if you if you look at across the board
of what the median salary is for a
teacher it's 60. now that means in some
districts in the united states like for
instance i got a friend who's teaching
high school in new york
upstate new york he's making over six
figures so this is across the board you
look at the median and now we go okay
this is what we're looking at in the
united states but again it is about how
they live on less than they make it's
not this study wasn't pointing to how
much they make it was how much they keep
and by the way there is one other
correlation between all of these
millionaires they love their work yeah
high quality
80 percentile range eighty percent they
so let me help you with this if you
invest from age 30 to age 65
in a decent growth stock mutual fund 15
of 60 000
you'll have 4.8 million dollars yeah
there it is now you can also
fire off a bunch of comments about that
but that was math that you don't really
get to negotiate with math yeah that's
how math works it just is or it isn't
that's right you don't get to make up
your own version that's not enough and
so if that's so if one if you only are
one-fifth as good as we teach right
i mean five million bucks 4.8 million
right okay you would still have one
million dollars right and from age 30 to
age 65
but dave that's all too clear cut and
simple for the keyboard warriors
there's got to be more complexity they
got to tear it apart it's got to be a
game
and that's unfortunate that's the sad
part the sad part is is that we have a
portion of our culture now who rather
than fix their life and address the
person in the mayor's deficits instead
wants a narrative that declares them a
victim there it is
that can't possibly be true dave because
if that's true i could do it
if you're if your study was accurate
what do you know about my study you just
you just
if your mouth was shut you wouldn't be
making noise oh my god
but dave they're mouth breathers so the
mouth can't be shut
seriously people
you really should abstain from the
comments section reading them or
commenting on them oh my gosh
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five you know i gotta i gotta
circle back one more time i can't just
can't let that lay um
there's a reason
that you and i both get so visibly
frustrated
with people that have a victim narrative
and insist on spreading their victim
narrative
we know
from
having worked with thousands and even
millions of people
that most anyone that follows a proven
process can go get a great job can get
out of debt and build wealth can have a
good marriage we know that people that
are that choose to control their
behavior in spite of the negative
influences from the outside in spite of
bad things having happened to them and
we all have challenges but in spite of
the challenges we know that people can
create for themselves carve out for
themselves a good life if they bother
when someone posts a negative narrative
that says oh teachers can't do it then
someone believes that or you're in an
echo chamber with a bunch of people that
says teachers can't do it then god help
us teachers believe they can't do it
and we know that that's not true and
you've then limited someone's belief in
someone's future and you've brought harm
to them and we love people and we love
people that so much we want them to win
and anything that keeps them from
winning including you debbie downers out
there we're you're going to be at the
tip of our sharp tongue yeah yeah i
agree with that and let me just say this
as much as we will take shots at people
that that are constantly negative and
cynical
i i do even you could do it if you quit
doing that i feel sadness over that
because because you've bought in some
form or fashion a false narrative you
have had some bad stuff happen to you
maybe somebody did something maybe you
made a mistake and you did something
dumb that doesn't disqualify you from
being a victor i've never read a
biography in my life and i've read a lot
of them uh where the the story the
person in the story that we're reading
about always did everything right had no
hardship had no self-inflicted wounds
had no disadvantages so i absolutely
agree with you we get fired up on this
because we're in the business of hope
we're in the business of giving people
hope that they can be who they're
supposed to be they can do what they
want to do um and yeah it really makes
me angry when people just go nah that's
all a pipe dream and uh yeah it
irritates us and and we live in a world
today where people really are influenced
shockingly by the comment in a comment
section by the negative yeah and yeah
that's why it fires up the negative the
negative good here's my deal if you
really believe that
then why do you feel like you got to
share that with everybody else i mean
you you have the right to believe and
say and i will always fight for liberty
to say and be negative and uh your if
that's what you want to be great but
don't bring it around the rest of us the
whole country's saying if you ain't got
something nice to say don't you say
nothing at all
i mean life is too short pastor friend
of mine used to say if it's not helpful
hopeful or promotes healing you don't
need to say it that's good
yeah it's not helpful hopeful or
promotes healing yeah you don't need to
say it yeah
and um
i i couldn't i could take it to that
advice occasionally too i just called a
whole bunch of people stupid so but
i think that might have been healing
though i think it was it was it was a
little therapeutic for both of us yeah
me and you were healed by it
yeah but i will say this i think it's
fair to say that someone is stupid or
unintelligent when they argue data
yeah but by the way those are the same
people that go science over here but
we're going to argue something we don't
like and he you've heard this before you
don't like it yeah that's right we hear
what we want to hear we see what we see
echo chamber city man it's just people
man man oh man ryan is with us in fresno
hi ryan welcome to the ramsay show
hi how's it going good man what's up
all right so question for you
i
made a
non-dave decision about four years ago
and i need your help getting out of it
okay
that's an interesting way of saying it
non-dave meaning it was a bad decision
well thanks for the compliment but
how can i help tell me what happened
yeah so my wife and i
went in on a property
with her
sister and
her husband
and it's 20 acres it has a primary house
and it had a mobile home on it
so my wife and i we took the primary
house
and
they took the mobile home it was all
agreed upon everything good
we decided to split the ownership
50 50.
but they get the trailer
that was
what we agreed on you're a good
negotiator
[Laughter]
yeah so i pay a little bit more for
homeowners insurance just because we are
in the primary house
we have to have two
separate homeowners insurance just i
don't know that's how they worked it out
anyways
my brother-in-law
they
either want us to all sell this place
together
or they want
me to buy him out
and we can't come
to an agreement on how we want to do
that we
basically our relationship is as
showered
and uh
so we're we're kind of at a standstill
of how we
how we can go about it
that's sad
yeah i don't know if i i don't know how
much help i can be with the relationship
part um
there's a i have a couple of thoughts on
structure if you want those you went
into it 50 50. so why don't you just
have the property appraised and pay him
50 percent
um
hello let's say the praise yeah can you
hear me yeah can you hear me oh
yes okay why don't you have an
apprentice
you put in 50 you each put in 50 right
and he got the short end of the stick
and lived in the trailer
all right yeah and now he wants to buy
out why can't you pay him 50 of the
value what's wrong with that
well the
value is somewhere around 400 000 yeah
and uh so that would mean
so how does that mean i'm paying him 200
000 or just
he owns 50 of it he bought 50 of it you
bought 50 of it
we don't we don't own the home outright
though
we're still paying on a mortgage
okay
together
yep
okay then it's four hundred thousand
uh minus the mortgages divided by two
okay uh so if it that you're saying the
total 20 acres and the two the house and
the trailer are worth 400 grand is that
what you're telling me
yeah okay and how much is the mortgage
uh we owe about 320 on it okay you're
gonna have to get that refinance to get
his name off of it for him to be free
but you've only got eighty 000 worth of
equity you need to write him a check for
40.
not really i'll come to that in a minute
but you're half you buy out his half
what's why is that complicated
uh i just i don't want to go into even
more
yet
i'm just i think i'm having trouble
figuring out how to i'm paying him 40
000
and then accruing
the remaining balance of the mortgage
yeah but you also own the property a
hundred percent okay
okay instead of owning a 200 000
property now you own a 400 000 property
that's good okay and so can you handle
the mortgage by yourself i think that
might be the problem
uh
yes yes they can what's your household
income
uh last year brought in about 72.
okay
you can't afford this
this payment by yourself can you
it's your household income you and your
wife
yeah my wife's to stay at home okay
all right we have a uh we we run a small
family ranch
where we live yeah i'm sorry sir i don't
think you can afford a 400 000 mortgage
or a 300 something thousand dollar
mortgage
150 000 mortgage on a 72 000 income
i don't think that's going to work well
for you
your payment when you take this out on a
15-year fix should be no more than a
fourth of your income i think you guys
are selling this property
that's what i think
and you guys are you and your wife are
gonna live somewhere else and your
brother-in-law's gonna live somewhere
else
that's a sad deal though it's
heartbreaking
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and
time-consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience
if someone from that company likes your
profile they can personally invite you
to apply for the job so if you're ready
for an easier job search check out
ziprecruiter sign up for free right now
at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
all right ken i want to revisit the last
caller because i had a thought all right
the break um a solution okay so let's
revisit he and
uh his wife's sister and his
brother-in-law the four of them bought a
property together 20 acres
uh they live in fresno california and it
has a trailer on it and a home on it
they moved into the home the
brother-in-law moved into the trailer
the brother something's gone sour and
the brother-in-law wants out he wants
out of the deal they both put in 50
percent so the property is currently
valued at 400 000
and they owe 320. those were the facts
going into the break okay
um
he makes 75 000 a year he can't afford
the payment on the whole thing if he
buys his brother-in-law out
uh it was my point going into the break
so that sounds like they're gonna be
forced to sell out of the whole thing i
did have another way because he's he
also said i think he's ranching on that
property he's so his
i was not only getting rid of his house
i was getting rid of his his job his
sole income yeah everything i mean his
whole life's upside down so i hated to
just throw him on the bus head into a
commercial break
so
here is a thought for ryan
um
[Music]
you can subdivide 20 acres
and uh take the 10 that you want to keep
and the 10 that the brother-in-law keeps
the brother-in-law sells his 20 acres or
his 10 acres and the trailer
is on that
he takes that money
pays half of the mortgage off because
he's liable for half of the mortgage the
mortgage is 320. so that puts it at 180.
did i do that right no no well
320 and a half is not one eight it's
160. thank you i'm the money guy keep it
keep this in mind i was a little nervous
heading into that to be honest with you
i did some quick math myself i was like
before i questioned
that i thought i thought i thought dave
yeah i had to take my shoes off under
the desk and use my toes
okay so 160 000 yeah all right so
brother-in-law pays off 160 000 right
whatever's left from the sale of the 10
acres after he pays off 160 000 he puts
in his pocket and walks away
i like that he's just been bought out
now then ryan has to go get a new
mortgage for 160 000
only owns 10 acres has no money out of
pocket
and um
he can put that on a 15 year and survive
making 75 000 that's right but you're
not going to have 20 acres ryan you're
going to have 10 acres
subdivided
10 acres each brother-in-law sells his
takes these money proceeds for the sale
pays off half of the mortgage
simultaneously ryan's gonna have to get
a new mortgage at the same closing table
for 160 000 to give clear title to the
new buyer on the 10 acres
the buyer on the 10 acres
and the brother is going to get whatever
if he sells that for 400 grand yeah he
whatever the brother can sell his
brother-in-law can sell his 10 acres for
he gets that money yeah minus 160. he
has to pay off his half of the mortgage
and then ryan can keep his property but
he's only going to keep the 10 acres
which is all he ever had to start with
right because it was a partnership on 20
acres yeah so um
now if ryan needs 20 acres to run his
ranch
i don't think he can afford it there's
the problem yep that's the only asterisk
there on that one yeah so um
and you're gonna have to find a way to
subdivide this but in most counties in
the united states of america you can
subdivide 20 down into 10.
very few places keep you from doing that
and sell it off and um then the
brother-in-law got what he got and
that's his half you don't have to argue
about what it's worth
he let the market tell him what it's
worth yeah
but he has to bring 160 out for his half
of the mortgage all right now we got
there i feel better about that solution
jonathan is with us in fort worth texas
if i pick up the right phone line anyway
there he is jonathan's in fort worth hey
jonathan how are you
hey dave i'm doing great thanks for uh
taking my call today sure what's up so
question i have uh my wife and i we've
been dave ramsey for a year and a half
and debt-free for a year
a little background story we're retired
military
and retired in texas but through that
process we had a house in another state
uh kept it as a rental for about the
past 10 years
and now we finally got it on the market
and we're going to close on it next
month
so the question is
the gross
amount that we earn from the sale of the
house
do we
pay that on our mortgage here in texas
we also have about 120 k in a
traditional ira
or do we pay to roll that to a rock
and then use the remaining balance to
pay off our
texas
mortgage wow
well nothing in the list is dumb
both things could be under the heading
of smart
according to what we teach on the baby
steps i would pay down the house in
texas because i don't convert to a roth
until baby steps seven
i don't i don't want to create taxes
until i get my house paid off
and so um what's the balance on your
home in texas
uh so the balance is at uh 480 k
we're on a 2.25 percent hdr
and we're on a
for the simple math it's a 30-year
mortgage it was cheaper at a third year
but we're paying it off at a 15-year
rate plus a little extra so i think
we're about on pace to do a
but the balance of the balance is how
much again
480. and what do you what how much are
you getting from the property that
you're selling
uh we're expecting the growth of about
200k oh excellent okay yeah i would
throw it at the house
okay here's the deal
i don't want to create taxes and give
the government the tax money while i've
still got house debt because effectively
you would have been borrowing on your
home to pay the roth ira taxation
follow me
okay that's why i did that
in other words if you've got
you know let's just pretend that you've
um
you owe 200 000 on your house
or 280 000 on your house okay
and you have the opportunity to convert
to your roth ira but it's going to
create 200 000 worth of taxes are you
going to go borrow 200 000 more on your
house in order to convert to a roth no
if you use this money to convert to a
roth it is exactly the same thing in a
balance sheet scenario where you lay it
out on the balance sheet you created the
same thing you just did it in reverse
and that's how i decided not to do that
that was the the thinking critical
thinking path i use
to say i wouldn't borrow on my house to
pay taxes on converting a traditional to
a roth and i won't pay
taxes converting a traditional to a roth
in lieu of paying down my house it's the
same thing but backwards that's all
that makes sense
i was following but the speed and the
pace by which you do it it i have to
really catch up i really do you you you
know 35 years of doing this is pretty
good folks so that's pretty good stuff
well it's not it's not rugged but it's
just
i have to think about how the stuff is
going where and
if i once i get that then i remember why
i have the baby steps that's because
word of mouth is a lot of times what
we're doing you and me is your your
clear path your steps of your you know
your your steps of
uh the seven stages
doing things you love right yeah uh
there there's a reason that they're
there right and when something comes up
and you go well i don't know yes this is
an exception
then you go no because that's right
here's the way i did that you'll walk it
back here's the logic oh sure yeah
if you do that then you can understand
oh well that's why the baby steps still
work after all these years yep that's
why your clear path to doing work you
love will still work 20 years from now
well one of the things that well when
you walk through that what it does is is
by by using that methodology and the way
you you kind of logically work through
that it also takes out the emotion which
i think is so important you know because
our emotions get in the way so many
times just could be a little emotion i
mean it doesn't have to be some big
fretful fearful thing it could be i got
a little bit of doubt is this the right
thing i'm a little bit nervous about
this you know there's a there's a you
know cornucopia of emotions that can get
us into a place where we go
uh and it's like no let's walk through
this from a process standpoint that's
the power process
yeah and um
so much of what we are trying to
influence you guys to do is a proven yes
process and his question is really
really good oh yeah because a high level
question very absolutely and and uh it's
also really good because neither answer
is in the stupid column that's right
it's not like he's got some bad options
do i lease a car or do i finance a car
yeah okay you know both in the stupid
column right so you know do i get a
mastercard or a visa that's right both
in the stupid column discover or
american distress yeah yes no both in
the stupid column whole life or
universal both in the stupid column
payday lender or timeshare both in the
stupid column you know i mean both of
his were in the smart column that's
right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you've been stressed
out about your retirement savings
because of everything going on in the
world should you really be concerned or
are you just in freak out mode
you know sometimes we get a little drama
queen inside of us right me as well
and that's why you need somebody in your
corner to help you with this stuff you
need someone to walk with you when
you're freaking out to teach you to talk
with you talk you off the ledge and go
don't jump off all roller coaster in the
middle of the ride
that's what you need to be reminded of
when it comes to investments what we
recommend is a smartvestor pro they're
investing professionals that we've
carefully vetted
smart vista pros have the heart
of a teacher and they agree with us on
what we teach
text invest to 33 789 and you can find a
list of the smart vester pros in your
area one of them will sit down with you
help you with a retirement plan help you
with an ira rollover a 401k rollover
help you get your kids college set up
and then when the market goes crazy you
can even talk to them about it and
they'll tell you what's really going on
text invest to 33
7
89. steven is in phoenix hi steven
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how you doing today better than
i deserve what's up
so
i've
made it to becoming debt-free except for
my mortgage
in arizona but
we're thinking about moving to florida
and i want to know if i should sell my
house in arizona and pay off on cash in
florida
uh
if you're moving to florida yes
okay what's the sole purpose of that
question are you moving to florida just
for cheaper housing or are you moving
for for purpose for professional for
family what's going on
so i run a crypto mining business out of
my house here but i'm in an hoa
and we're looking for states that
i guess more leaning towards the red
side more freedom
oriented but
i just have to convince my wife
to sell our house here because we
currently have a mortgage
to just pay for one cash
outright in florida without an hoa so i
can grow the business as well
have you done your homework on a
specific spot in florida that you got in
mind here is this is this all
theoretical
no so i've done research i'm looking
north of orlando kind of near the deland
area for about
uh around an acre or so
is what we're looking for to set up like
a mining shed
um
it's just kind of convincing my wife to
get on board with the whole idea because
it's kind of like a big it feels like a
big risk
why is it a big risk
uh it's just a big change i think and
she's just worried about it
maybe the mining business not working
out in the future because it flows with
the market
so it's not always profitable
right
but that's true in arizona and in
florida
yeah exactly so so having no mortgage in
florida
while you're in an unbelievably high
risk business
would be less stressful than having a
mortgage in arizona while you're in an
unbelievably high risk business
how old are you
29
yeah
i think your wife's telling you she
doesn't like what you do for a living
for risk-wise
i think that's what's happening i could
be wrong could be some family involved
you know didn't want to leave family i
mean this is this is a marriage issue
here this is some communication sit down
and get on the same page are we together
the problem is is you're trying to
reduce
um
your entire life
which is your relationships your church
your where you shop for groceries
um where
you uh
how how close you are to relatives
um all of that down to a decision on
whether you have a shed
or a mortgage
and
it's not it's not that simple there's
more variables involved and even
one of the variables is it that you're
in an unbelievably high risk business
and um the uh
your your wife um
uh uh is
i think she may be saying that to you uh
maybe she doesn't even know she's saying
that to you but that's scaring her
and because you know our
but but it's not as simple as
housing is cheaper north of atlanta
north of orlando an hour than it is in
phoenix which it is but there's parts of
orlando that are not cheaper than
phoenix so you know if you go north of
phoenix well not north of phoenix but if
you go outside of phoenix an hour
probably not north or sedona but if you
go a different direction you might find
land that's very very cheap there too
without an hoa and if you sold your
house in phoenix proper like if you're
sitting in scottsdale which is a very
expensive market you could move out of
there and probably pay cash for
something an hour outside of phoenix so
i i don't care where you live yeah and i
just want to point out that uh what it
feels like dave is that okay uh this is
really risky it's making my wife nervous
but i can buy some more time
to keep going with this risky business
if i remove my mortgage and i just need
a little more time and and
i i feel like there's something there
that's that's right and i would also
point out that knows the governor of
arizona is a very very strong liberty
champion so arizona is not
the the politics in arizona florida blue
state no no they're not different so i
just want to point that out i'm trying
to take away the excuses yeah josh is in
nashville hey josh welcome to the ramsey
show okay
hey did anything
sure what's up
hello hello what's up hey hey i was just
i was calling to ask a quick question
about some student loan guidance
um i'm a physician assistant i just got
married
about a year ago i've been working for a
year congrats
yeah thank you uh me and my wife have a
we have uh a lot of money in our
checking account because we don't spend
anything
uh we don't have a car payment we're
renting a townhouse and we just don't
know what to do as far as paying off
loans versus
starting to invest and kind of where to
even start
cool how much is in your checking
account
uh we have about 40 grand um in checking
and then four or five in kind of an
emerging a little emergency uh separate
account okay um and it's just sitting
there kind of doing nothing
and your wife is what
um she's a speech-language pathologist
she works uh part-time from home right
now for the covenant two phenomenal
careers with high income potential
what's your household income
uh
right now it varies um because i work in
the emergency room so hours kind of
swing but generally it'll be from
140 to 160 um yearly yeah i think both
of you get kicking in you probably break
a 200 pretty quick between the two of
you very good
very good okay well what we know and
what data data tells us in 30 years of
doing this is that the quickest play
between where you are now and wealth is
first to alleviate debt because it's the
biggest blocker for you on wealth
building
and it adds risk to your life and so
we're going to attack the student loans
with a vengeance
if i'm in your shoes
and to the point that your friends think
you've lost your mind
okay and we're gonna get on a tight
beans and rice rice and beans budget
we're gonna take all the ot we can get
and we're gonna drop 39 of the 40 on
this student loan today and we're going
to put a tight written budget together
and begin to attack the rest of this you
will be blown away that you're going to
be debt free in under two years maybe as
quick as a year
oh wow but you're gonna have no life
during that time you understand that
yeah yeah and we just you know you don't
have a life anyway you don't spend money
yeah we we take cheap vacations and kind
of you know make one dime thing but yeah
but what if you did nothing except pay
on debt for one year
and you made 160. oh by the way you said
you said you had 150 but we just put 30
or 40 on it so you got 110 now i mean
how quick can you pay off 110 if you
didn't do anything else you might do it
in a year
yeah we could probably get rid of it
real fast yeah and see then you got the
whole rest of your life
to become wealthy without that stinking
sally mae in your spare bedroom
yeah yeah that's what we teach think
about
what do you think about you know because
the more we talk about it the more we
think of oh we don't have any
investments you'll get your investments
you're going to be making 200 and
something thousand dollars a year and no
debt you'll be able to invest like a
maniac
all right well you know i told my wife
i'd call and ask but i think everything
you're saying she said you would say oh
i think she set you up yeah
hang on i'm going to give you a gift i
want the two of you to go through ramsay
plus our financial peace university and
i'm gonna give you ramsey plus a
membership for a year because you guys
have got real potential if you follow
what we're teaching i'm gonna give it to
you free won't cost you a thing i just
expect you to watch the dadgum videos
and go do what we teach i want you to
win dude hold on it's our late wedding
gift to you kelly will pick up
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for jumping in america this is your
show open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the new
book from paycheck to purpose the clear
path to doing work you love
is my co-host today so we'll take your
questions about your life your career
your job which he talks about on ken
coleman
on the ken coleman show every day on 75
radio stations a podcast on youtube and
i will take them right here as well and
we'll talk about your life and your
money free call at triple eight eight
two
825-5225 christy is with us in asheville
north carolina hi christy how are you
hey dave i'm good um thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's up
um first i wanted to say thank you
because um just going through your
program we are debt-free including our
home yay and thank you yes um so we are
you know we're doing step four and we're
about to start step five
our daughter is seven years old and
we're trying to decide between the 529
or the esa and
kind of leaning towards the esa because
by the time she's 18 that'll probably be
enough because we don't want to put too
much and you know pay for stupidity
so
um
so just kind of wanted your opinion on
the differences
okay all right well to clarify if your
home is paid for you're a baby step
seven
and so now you're safe you're continuing
to save for retirement continuing to
save for uh
college but this is all just wealth
building baby step seven's just become
wealthy and outrageously generous so if
you have an emergency fund you're 100
debt free house and everything you're at
baby step seven but anyway
um the esa and the 520 and are kissing
cousins obviously they're very similar
esa's educational savings account
it is only
one thing
it is only
two thousand dollars a year
and it is only for people that make less
than two hundred thousand dollars of
your household income
and it only grows
tax free
and there is no tax deduction for what
you put into it and so if you put a
mutual fund into an esa it's going to
grow tax free
for the number of years you can put up
to 2 000 per year into that and that's
it
very simple very cut and dried it can't
be anything else
529 has a bunch of things under that
heading
a lot of which we don't recommend
for instance prepaid college plans with
some of the states are technically 529
plans
there's another kind of 529 that locks
in the investments and they're frozen
you can't move them once you pick them
they're fixed the entire time no
flexibility bad 529 there's another kind
of 529 that's a life phase where they
move the investments to more
conservative investments less risky
investments as the child ages
automatically i don't want you to do
that i want you to manage the money
okay
the only kind of 529 we have is where
you pick the mutual funds just like you
do in the essay so they're just a like
like that you invest in them and you
completely control them they will not
move unless you move them
and no one else is going to do it for
you and you're in charge okay just like
the esa now so once you've done that if
it's that kind of 529 the differences in
the 529 the essay are not many both are
after tax investments both grow
tax
free
both allow you to control and move the
investments inside of them as many times
as you need to and within the mutual
fund families particularly is a great
idea
okay so all of that's the same you're
you do not have an income limit of 200
household income limit of 200 000 on the
529 and you are not limited to the 2 000
per year most 529s allow up to 10 000 a
year some even more
so if you want to put more money in or
you make a little more money
that type of 529 does exactly the same
thing but allows you to put in a little
bit more and deal with a little bit more
or if you're like if you're playing
catch-up and you make 300 000 a year you
want to dump some money in that's fine
but if you got a baby
and you make over under 200 grand and
you can drop two grand a year into it
you're gonna be just fine you're gonna
you have a lot of money you have 150 000
bucks probably in there but if it's in a
good mutual fund by the time that baby's
18 and like you said that's enough to
get start making some really good
choices you're probably going to have
some other wealth if you want to add to
it
and you're going to be in really really
good shape so very well done it's an
interesting discussion and it's great to
get ahead of it and it can it really is
because when you start to think about
you know if any investing advice or
thinking about in you know putting money
away and watching that compound
it doesn't have to be a lot and that's a
wonderful example on how you can well i
mean 150 000 for one kid is more than
enough for any kind of quality education
that you're looking at today i don't
know about 20 years from now well that's
a great point that's a whole other
discussion yeah but it's a good
discussion it really is because higher
education
i think it has problems uh it's very
susceptible right now there's no
question i think this idea that they
just get to keep raising the price
forever is over i do think that is over
i think you're gonna see the cost of
which i think you're seeing splintering
um you know i think you're going to see
more and more organizations training
people
for the jobs at hand google's already
doing this they've come out and it's
very very clear move into the
marketplace and you're going to see
other large companies come alongside of
them so uh that should be plenty of
money we hope uh i think it will be but
that is a separate prediction and
conversation but the cost of college and
and higher ed is gonna have to
it's gonna have to be reckoned with
because i think this this student loan
of course we got this great documentary
coming out borrowed future it's going to
absolutely punch all this right in the
face and i hope tip the domino i believe
borrowed future our documentary could be
dave the tipping point that finally i
believe
we make this a more mainstream
conversation
we all are pretty much in agreement that
the student loan program is an epic
failure absolutely we're all pretty much
in agreement that this unfettered flow
of money out of washington
to these universities has caused them to
without without reservation raise price
after price price after price price so
the supply of cash has driven the price
up unbelievably yeah and then you add to
that the pandemic comes along and now
they want to charge just as much for you
sitting at home that's right now there's
no football games yeah well now there is
but i mean now there's no campus
experience no now there's no this or
you've got all this woke stuff and other
stuff going on to the point people don't
they're not even going for education
anymore now we're going for the cultural
experience right and uh nobody wants to
pay 200 grand for that anymore no and
the swollen endowments right we got all
this money sitting over here and we're
not helping kids that need some
financial aid the narrative is just
really snowballing poorly yeah it's not
it's not going to go well for higher ed
um and i'm not against higher ed no
we're not no we are not we're we're
proponents of it but uh uh once you be
sure and check out borrowed future it's
going to be anywhere that you want to
plug in to see a paid documentary you'll
be able to watch it um it's coming out
the uh
in october uh the 13th 13th i believe it
is yeah i think so
hope that's a friday
no correction do we have that right yeah
what is it what are you saying fourteen
fourteen okay okay good close enough
you'll be able to find it right there in
the middle of october yes sir borrowed
future it's a big premiere we did a
whole thing here the other day with it
it's
the whole team watched it and it will
make you so angry when you see how nasty
these people are behind the scenes
this is the ramsey show
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me and thirty thousand dollars
all thanks to what i learned at bethel
tech you could be next get started today
at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's bethel betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ken coleman's new book is from paycheck
to purpose the clear path to doing
work you love
[Music]
ken this is um
more than just climbing the career
ladder this is more than just making
more money yeah this is
about income and impact everybody wants
to make a difference in this world we
just do it doesn't matter where you're
from what you believe
uh your politics doesn't matter
everybody wants to make a difference and
there is this world view of work that
says i just work to be able to get a
paycheck to be able to live that's the
provision piece but you and i know that
there's contribution and that's what
that title in four words really outlines
the provision is the paycheck but
purpose is the contribution and this is
a seven stage clear path is what this
book is about that not only helps you
figure out what meaningful work is what
work that i love to do is what is this
work i was born to do this contribution
i was created to make it only helps you
there but then it walks you through the
journey it's not just get clear it's
then get qualified how do you get
qualified the right way for less money
but gets me into the door how do i get
connected so opportunities show up and
knock on my door how do i start where do
i start the right place so that i'm on
the right ladder how do i get promoted
that bigger shovel hello more money more
impact how do i get the dream job and
then what what does it mean to give
ourselves away that's just a real quick
you know pass through the seven stages
but it is a clear path that shows you
what you could do and tells you that you
should do it and uh it demystifies this
climb that so many people think and you
know i was just thinking for a moment
when i talk about this why did i write
this book and what is how does this play
into the money game that we talk about
i've never once now i'm sure there's
been one or two
but i've never once in my time here
seven years at ramsey solutions heard a
debt free screen where the income did
not go up on some level and there's more
to it than just
you know well we were getting after it
and we were trying to hustle through it
there was a vision
and that's what drove everything else
the intensity the gazelle intensity is
about the vision the baby steps give and
this idea of working for purpose
it's more than just income and we can
help you get the bigger shovel and move
up but more importantly wants you to do
work that you love so that when you get
to the end of your life dave you look
back and you reminisce on the impact you
made you don't regret that you just
worked for a paycheck and that's what
this is about yeah this is a a lifelong
guide yeah this isn't a quick thing you
need a better job no no this is not uh
this is going to walk with you the whole
way
building your career helping you step
through the leadership ladder yeah
making an impact coming home and going
because what satisfies you and rings
your purpose bill today won't 10 years
from now that's correct your vision
grows i've always run ramsey for 30
years based on purpose but my purpose
has evolved and yes it is absolutely for
sure that's right and so that would be
true in any career path i'm no different
than anybody else in that regard yeah so
if you pre-order today the book will
come out november the 9th and we will
ship them to you to where they're on
your doorstep that day
you're going to get also
the get a promoted bonus pack 20 bucks
for the book and it includes over 100
worth of stuff now here's what comes
free the promoted the get promoted audio
lesson from ken
the disc assessment
and from the paycheck to the the from
paycheck to purpose live event
and a 30-day free trial to ramsey plus
and more
and over a hundred dollars worth of free
stuff total to get you started and get
you set apart from the competition
ramsey solutions dot com to pre-order
the copy of the new book paycheck from
paycheck to purpose only 20 again street
date on this is november the 9th our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings they do a great job
that's it they have free samples free
shipping the new promos they run all the
time you'll save even more use the promo
code ramsey to get the best possible
deal today's oh sorry dave go ahead
rules and restrictions apply cut him off
folks i'm so excited to get to amy's
question from kansas i applied for a job
with a salary range of 16 to 18 an hour
which would be a raise from what i'm
making now i went to the interview and i
know i did well they looked up how much
i should get paid for the job based on
my credentials and it came out to about
25 an hour i'm afraid that their budget
may get in the way of me being
considered for the opening this job is
very specialized and it's not something
everyone can do what uh would
what i should be paid
disqualify me from getting the job so
what amy's asking here is hey they
looked it up and they think i'm gonna
want 25 an hour uh but uh this is what
they think you're not going to stay
because you're going to get 25 that's
right so what do i do so here's the deal
it shouldn't keep you from getting the
job amy if you communicate properly and
the fact that you've already they've
already told you well we think it's 25
hours what uh what you could make you
got to go hey
it was advertised at 16 18 or that's
what you told me and i'm thrilled to
jump in at 18 i'm ready to go or
whatever they offer i want to prove
myself i want to grow i want to do this
work don't let that bother you i think
this is a good fit you got to
communicate that and i think that
humility
but just straight up honesty that you
want the gig and tell them why you want
the gig
don't let their worries and their fears
or what you think maybe their worries
and fears fit into this you just tell
them i want the gig and i'll be thrilled
to take the gig so and
here's the thing
the kids my kids years ago there's a
thousand years ago they were teenagers
it feels like but they had this thing
what they did and they called it awkward
turtle right
and that was if a conversation is
awkward yeah
what do you do oh this is awkward it's
an awkward moment right right and you
know that's what this is that's exactly
right and the best way
for the elephant in the room to
magically disappear is to say
there's an elephant in the room great
it's so true
yeah yeah he goes away yeah here's the
elephant
you guys looked it up
and this job pays 25 an hour you don't
have the budget for that you're afraid
i'm gonna leave because somebody's to
offer me 25 an hour i'm saying i'm not
doing that i'm taking the job you need
to hire me this is a done deal quit your
fretting yeah you say that poof yeah
there's nothing to be tense about here
yeah yeah just
whether they believe you on that or not
but
here's the thing people are paying some
ridiculous figures yeah for jobs for
people to move now i'm hearing just some
bizarre numbers on things oh out there
just to get human beings to show up to
work yeah it's going to blow their mind
when you tell them you want the gig yeah
they're gonna look at you like you got
horns growing out of your head you know
we get in trouble sometimes that boy
i've been married 23 years coming up on
24 years and the biggest trouble i've
ever gotten into dave with stacy is when
i try to assume or try to anticipate
what she's thinking as opposed to just
talking to her plainly or asking her
questions when i try to anticipate or
try to analyze something that's not
there boy we get this thing all worked
up on our head and it's not that big a
deal
just tell them i want the gig there's so
much low-hanging fruit at the here that
i could come with
there's no way that you could know
what's in stacy's head because it's way
smarter than yours this comes to mind
doesn't it it's just one item
you're absolutely right that's just one
of the myriad of reasons why i shouldn't
do it
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
no i mean yeah that the thing is
if
if something is weird stressful
um
the
the the demons around this they don't
like light yeah and when you shine light
on it they run for the corners the
roaches run for the corners as soon as
you turn the lights on and awkward
conversations have that sense to them
that you know this is a difficult yeah
thing for me to cover yeah this is a
hard thing for us to talk about this is
a weird thing for us to talk about
uh but by talking about it it loses all
of its power so true yeah and many times
what we think is going to be awkward for
us isn't awkward for the other party so
just be an adult
have a good posture a good spirit about
you and as you said i was in your shoes
i might be thinking she's going to leave
and take the twenty-five dollars
i love that so why do i wanna put her in
there only to lose her in just a few
months i want you to know i've already
thought about that and i plan on staying
and i'd be honored to take this position
i would like to know how i can even add
more value over time to where i could
make 25 but you'd be happy to pay me
that because i made you fifty dollars
that's cool so i mean that kind of a
conversation is really powerful and oh
yeah as a follow-up after an interview
that would be pretty strong yeah they'll
be in a hurry to sign you
i think so yeah
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
great
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage evan and liz are with us
hey guys how are you hi dave great dave
welcome where do you all live
we are just north of detroit in michigan
oh wonderful okay like rochester or
ferndale
between rochester and detroit perfect
cool well good to have you guys welcome
to nashville and to do a debt free
scream how much have you paid off
93 000 in 27 months hey good numbers and
your range of income during that time uh
we started around 80 and finished around
1 30. good what do you guys do for a
living
liz works in the home
and i work in
systems administration a lot of
automation powershell that kind of thing
cool i.t computers i can tell that
that kind of stuff yeah so i got to ask
real quick what's what led to the big
jump here that's a big jump yeah uh
we got gazelle intense at some point
during our journey we we got to the
point where we couldn't scrape any more
off the budget and had to just get a
bigger shovel um so how did you increase
your income 50 grand yes
yeah no it sounds crazy um
certifications and make sure that and
getting the right job um just found a
you change jobs uh employers um so just
working my way up
so you got qualified and you got
promoted very good there you go nice
good work wow and he got the old company
to pay for the certification they paid
for some furthering education and then
he leveraged that wow
very good
well those starts are very valuable
obviously well done good for you guys
what kind of debt was the 93 oh a little
bit everything but mostly student loans
student loans overwhelmingly student
loans how much of it was student loans
i'd say 85 oh wow hardly anything else
yeah yeah yes we had a tiny car loan
a tiny medical loan
yeah how long you all been married uh
nine years yeah
yeah
what happened uh 27 months ago two years
and some change
yeah we finally had the i've had it
moment that you've talked about um where
we were making very decent money and all
of a sudden all of it was going out the
door to other people and it didn't make
a lot of sense to us to keep that around
so we listened to your book on a road
trip or i did for work and it just made
sense it clicked it was within like
spitting distance oh we could do this
like it's not just far off thing that
like only superheroes can do like we can
just make this happen wow that's a good
line i love that yeah there's some depth
there's not just for superheroes we can
do this yes and you are superheroes by
the way but uh just the same so you came
home from the road trip and say liz i've
been listening to audiobooks
uh no i said we should sign up for a
financial piece
she said well we had heard about it
before um but our good friends at our
church um he was leading the class and i
was like fine i'll do it oh that made it
up
and so then we took the class together
and
i felt like for the first time in our
marriage we were really aligned on
what our plan was going to be yeah
financial peace university your friend
is teaching it you join the class yeah
okay
i'm always interested in this i mean
i've been doing this for 30 years but
i'm still it's always intriguing to me
because i know how my brain works when
i'm going into something like that i
walk into that class i've got all of my
cynical shields up i mean
cynicism is a spiritual gift for me i
mean you know it's just like i i i was
i'm thinking there's this is greasy this
is slimy this guy's trying to get my
money
and uh
and i i'm gonna be pretty cynical you
might not have been that jaded but um
but you still have to not know what you
know it never is what you think it's
going to be you know what i'm saying
yeah you think it's one thing but it was
something else what were you thinking it
was going to be and what was it um
i think for me um i thought it was going
to be kind of this like
health wealth prosperity like just
trying to make yourself rich for the
sake of making yourself rich and i think
what really sold me was your vision of
generosity to people
that it just had it's not just about you
it's about it's so that you can help
others and um i used to be a teacher in
detroit before
we had kids and so i just felt like that
really resonated with me this is an
important way to
get our situation together so that we
can do more of what we want to do for
other people
yeah
yeah that does change that changes the
nobility of it um to say it's about
others and because it is yeah but it
changes the spirit on how you're going
um and so you just come home from the
first class and say game on we're doing
it huh
yeah um
i mean it was overwhelming at first um
when we ran our initial numbers i think
it was like in five years at this
trajectory um then we'll be debt free
and
um
yeah but we just
saw the lord's faithfulness i think
every month just like
paying off more than we even anticipated
we'd be able to pay off in little ways
um
and so i think that motivated us and as
we saw our
on our spreadsheet yeah it just the time
kept decreasing and decreasing so yeah
evan it's fun when spread streets quit
working
it's going faster than we thought this
is going good yeah it builds up
emotional psychological spiritual
momentum yeah absolutely yep 100 wow wow
i want to ask you this you just talked
about that overwhelming you know it's
just so much to take in right
and you go home and you put the first
plan together five years boy that feels
like forever right
but at some point you get to
uh that class and i'm just wondering how
much the community of other people going
through it
help you not be so overwhelmed with the
climb you're not alone speak to that and
what that felt like going through it
with other people yeah absolutely i
think the transformation in our marriage
was
we were at a point where we both felt
like we were dealing with finances
separate
um and then all of a sudden we started
having these conversations and i think
the same thing happened within our
community at church where we're not
having to deal with the separate
struggles yeah but now we're very open
with our numbers very i mean we just
televised our numbers
right everybody right
we can be open with that we could say
hey we struggled hey we never talked
about finances the first eight years of
our marriage for seven years of our
marriage and we were it wasn't good like
we didn't have shared values we didn't
have these shared things and i feel like
it opens a avenue of vulnerability um
[Music]
that's powerful can i think a sense of
freedom that yeah you're not defined by
this like it's okay this doesn't define
who you are as a person
yeah there's no stain on you there's
there's a brighter future removes the
shame yeah yeah that's good way to go
guys
heroes man look at you how's it feel to
be free amazing so good just
yeah was it worth the sacrifice it was
it was worth it and worth it for our
kids and
um
just we have hope for them for the
future um so we're really what was the
weirdest thing you did to cut spending
down to nothing
i don't know about cutting spending we
lived really minimally um
but
he did some funky things for side gigs
before he got the job promotion oh okay
yeah i think the weirdest thing was
score keeping at a table talk hockey
tournament one weekend
for like a 200 bucks
score keeper yeah craigslist man no not
just score keeper table table hockey
table yes yeah that is this is like on
your resume right here man i love it
that's fun
well done yeah score ding
by the way don't call us and tell us
there's not a way to make extra money
the man made a hundred dollars score
keeping scorekeeping for table top
hockey yeah
this is awesome i love you guys yeah
this is that's you're my kind of folk i
like that well done hey we got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that's the
copy that's the next chapter in your
story moving on to baby step
millionaires you're on your way without
a doubt and uh congratulations we're
very very proud of you also a copy of
total money makeover for your giveaway
to somebody get them started like that
audiobook got you hooked and then you
end up in financial peace university and
now you end up here 93 000
lighter all right it's evan and liz
detroit michigan area 93 000 paid off in
27 months making 80 to 130 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
their church and their group at
financial peace everybody cheering them
on that's amazing yes well done
good community you gotta have people
around you loving you well
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 22 3 the
prudence see danger and take refuge but
the simple keep going and pay the
penalty
dale carnegie said be more concerned
with your character
than with your reputation your character
is what you really are while your
reputation is merely what others think
you are in a social media age ken that
is a good thing right there to read
again yes it is
be more concerned with your character
than with your reputation yeah your
character is what you really are
while your reputation is merely what
others think you are yeah there you go
just like that turns out dave too that
when you actually are a person of
character your reputation's really good
most of the time
generally yeah yeah yeah but with social
media they oh you mean it all can take
out yeah sure sure people take shots
that aren't true but those that actually
about me about this place you know but a
stranger doesn't get to say what they
think dave's dave ramsey's reputation is
in my opinion stranger doesn't know you
i don't i discount that you know they
got to know you anybody who knows you
friends people who work closely with you
you have a reputation that is what
everybody hears and says out there very
different that's all i'm gonna say okay
that makes sense you know okay when
you're a person of character your
reputation with the right people takes
care of itself yeah i got you okay
tyler with the ones that matter yes
tyler's in state college pennsylvania hi
tyler how are you
hey dave doing great how about you
better than i deserve what's up
yeah so my question is related to
business and checking accounts i'm a
business owner i've always operated my
business out of a business checking
account along with a business debit card
as the business scaled up over the years
my expenses are becoming a little bit
higher and more frequent and my current
card only has a 2500 limit
and each time that i go above that i get
a call into the bank and each time
they're really pressing me on the
business credit card
and just today when i went to do it they
actually denied it all together and
weren't going to let me do it unless i
upgraded to their business credit card
so i guess my question is
what do you recommend that like how are
you running your business being like a
multi-million dollar business and all
that what's your recommendation there
uh it's time to change banks dude
yeah that's what i'm thinking yeah
see they got confused
about who the customer is
yeah the customer was sitting in front
of them telling them what he wanted and
they start putting demands on you on how
you're going to use your money
in order to have the privilege of doing
business with these doofus i'm out of
there man the spirit on that is pitiful
yeah
i don't care even if it wasn't in
violation of what i teach just the way
they treated you today dude
right
that's what i'm talking about so here's
what we've had to do uh we've got i
think uh
lord i've lost count because i don't
keep up with it daily anymore i used to
be real concerned with it but anymore i
think we've got 150 people carrying
debit cards out of our thousands
um and a whole bunch of others that have
access to the numbers in order to do
orders with you know around here for
business purposes so
um
you know we've got a bunch of them i
obviously have a business debit card on
this place and the revenues here north
of 300 million a year so
um
i i have low tolerance for trying to use
that card and not buying whatever the
flip i wanted to buy okay yeah i mean so
uh i've we've had discussions with the
business banking
unit
um here and said look uh
my card
i'm not i mean you can put ten thousand
dollar twenty thousand dollar limit on
it the number of times i'm gonna buy a
car on a car it's zero anyway so i don't
really have anything i don't i don't
don't buy
uh stuff like that all the time but i
also don't want to not have access to
money when i've got millions of dollars
in your bank that will piss me off
because of your little debit card rules
but uh so we've had on my personal debit
card from the business had them give a
special dispensation
they should do that for you
um and you know 2500 is ridiculous it
ought to be at least five
and um
and you can look at it and you'll
probably be surprised the number of
times you go above five unless you're
doing a bunch of travel or something is
unusual anyway
yeah yeah so unusually low so um yeah
you need to change banks based on that
spirit
but uh you know we've got different
uh people inside this you know for
instance if one of our live event
producers is going to book a block of
rooms you know we're going into a hyatt
and we're going to take down 150 rooms
and they want a card well obviously
you know a daily limit is going to be a
problem on that so you know we and
that's how we use our debit cards here
so we we have some interaction with the
bank on a regular basis but we also have
uh higher than normal limits on some of
the daily amounts and total amounts on
the cards
obviously the cash has to be in the
account to coverage as a debit card um
that's not what we're discussing here
but i think more than anything else what
you're discovering is you have a bank
that doesn't understand your value as a
customer and you need to find one that
does value you by the way we did change
banks and one of the reasons was the
old bank that i've been with for a
thousand years uh got bought up and
bought up a bunch of stuff and became
much more corporatized and became
inflexible
even with an account our size
they started giving us a hard time on
all kinds of different things and we're
just like you know what
i'm not negotiating with you people
you're just a
flipping bank i mean there's one on
every corner there's a lot of them would
like to have our account a lot of them
like to have your account tyler i'd go
get somebody else what are you thinking
i think i think you're absolutely right
you know it's your money and uh these
are somebody made a decision on the 5th
or 6th or 15th or 25th floor
and
i think the spirit is absolutely
it's wrong they don't want to help you
grow they just got their rules and i'd
take off i'd go talk to some other bank
and go hey here's the deal here's what
i'm looking for
and and look him in the eye and uh
interview them interview banks just like
you would
like one of our elps i'm getting ready
to hire you for my banking services yeah
i'm a small business are you good enough
yeah stay out of my way can you let me
do my thing if so i'll bring my money to
you what's happening is this that guy's
dealing with a branch manager who's got
pressure on him to meet the quota yep
that a certain uh he has to move a
certain number of credit cards certain
number of business credit cards a month
and he's got people breathing down his
neck he's got a quota like he's selling
encyclopedias door-to-door exactly right
and these bankers have been reduced to
use car salesmen yeah these car salesmen
are much better people
and so uh sorry about that used car guys
you guys are excellent compared but i
mean they've been reduced to sales
people that have quotas yep i mean if
you work in victoria's secret and you
don't sell a lot of small underwear
that's not what they
gage you on
you can sell no small underwear and work
at victoria's secret as long as you sell
as long as you sell their credit card
because that's what they want oh they
want you charging small underwear okay i
didn't know where we were going with
this i was i was waiting to see what was
telling you this is it is it's
victoria's secret they are in the v
they're in the credit card business
always
retail i mean it's just you know
there's just nothing there there's there
it's just it's the same thing with most
of these companies yeah you go in a
department store why do you think
they're pushing the card on you they
make more money on that they do the
stinking merchandise it's absolutely on
their shelf it's become that credit card
game and that's what these guys are
doing this stupid bank here yeah this
bank deserves a good firing hmm
i like it
you're fired yeah
plenty of banks by the way
i tell you what you know i would go
interview the smaller banks yeah you're
the best bank of america i'll just bet
you oh i should have asked him yeah i'll
bet you it's bank of america it's that's
the way they act it's a big bank or big
ear yeah it's not it's not a small local
bank
small local bank would actually care
what you think yep and uh that's what
you need to go with by the way get you a
good regional bank or a small loan
that's one thing too we moved to a we
moved to a local that's what we did and
they can handle us i mean
we we have a lot of money over there but
they can handle it so yeah
mr drysdale or something but um y'all
don't even know who that is out there
you poor people in america
your television deficit
you don't know about the beverly
hillbillies i i feel so happy right now
that you just said mr drysdale kelly's
feeling the same thing we're the same
age we're not going to say the age so
kelly doesn't hit me after the show's
over
i know i know you're a little bit older
but mr drysdale that is classic tv right
there that's classic i mean but i mean
that's a banker who was beholden to the
rich oil barrier
in the beverly hillbillies okay and he
ran around all the time trying to make
his customer happy that's what you want
it's been since the 1950s and 60s with
black and white tv since bankers
understood what their freaking job was
that's so good and it's not to sell you
a credit card that's supposed to make
you the depositor happy yeah oh man
what a lost world we live in i know i'm
gonna go home and watch the beverly
hillbillies it's got to be on so i've
got two references to them in three
hours you have have you seen a show
lately no when you were channeling i'm
having i'm having flashbacks okay from
my childhood that's all it is it's an
old man thing
the old man flashbacks ken called me
good job today good job james childs
good job kelly daniels in the booth i am
dave ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you